ich bin konrad schuller redakteur der
faz sonntagszeitung im augenblick an der
ukrainisch polnischen grenze am kleinen
grenzübergang dollar budget in einer auf
wangs einrichtung für ukrainische
flüchtlinge die man hinter
nacht verlief in nürnberg mit einem
luftalarm mit einem bombenalarm um sechs
uhr morgens hörte dann die polizeistunde
auf da startete ich mit einem
ukrainischen vater und einer kleinen
ukrainischen familie die aus kies gerade
gekommen waren es liegt ja unter
bombardement das fasten haben in
sicht erst mal zur ukrainischen
westgrenze in einem total überfüllten
zug
durchgeschlagen zu krallen von einem
über zehn stunden nur einem halben bein
stehen konnte diese leute hatten ein
paar tage in lembeck in relativer
sicherheit ausgehe
ausgebuht hatten sich ein bisschen
erholt und dann sind wir heute früh mit
einem lemberger taxi zur zur polnischen
grenze gefahren da war an dem
grenzübergangs punkt etwas weiter
nördlich nach belarus die lage relativ
entspannt
das heißt wir sind mit einer wartezeit
von etwa zwei stunden über die grenze
gekommen und dann in den wirklich
überwältigend freundlichen polnischen
empfang gekommen
es wird praktisch vor helfern und vor
aufgestellten wärme zelten und das
dampfen über suppen töpfe und es riecht
nach
würsten und überall wird man spontan von
menschen angesprochen
aachen sid brauchen sie so verbrauchen
sind butterbrot es stehen leute da die
rufen ziele aus es wird dann wird
ausgerufen warschau krakau posen
so und sie sehen hinter mir das in
spielsachen da sind kinder da sind
menschen in weißen in gelben westen die
mögliche behörden repräsentieren das ist
also dann ist
ein rapidler sind der polizei des
grenzschutzes man kann alles wissen
fragen stellen es stehen dort jetzt mit
west nach denen anwalt darauf steht man
kann rechtliche fragen klären
das heißt das ist schon beeindruckend
wie sich polen her und die leute
gekümmert
[Musik]
ich war ja ein paar tage als
korrespondent in lemberg und da die das
ist einfach so berufliches tageweise im
taxi fahrer angeheuert und dieser
taxifahrer hat dann mich und die familie
unsere fotografen dann zur grenze
gebracht das waren so zweieinhalb
stunden die straßen baden okay die waren
nicht überfüllt man muss in der ukraine
immer wieder durch die straßen
kontrollpunkte der freiwilligen
territorialverteidigung durch tragen das
ist muss man sich so vorstellen da
werden meistens wenn sie das haben große
betonblöcke auf die fahrbahn gelegt
durch die man dann so im zickzack durch
farben muster dann ist man gezwungen zu
verlangsamen und
selbstgemachte sandsack burgen und
graben sich auch schützengräben man hört
dann die schaufeln klappern und
eigentliche markt wurden werden zu zu
ihren unterkünften gemacht weil es noch
die ganze nacht dastehen
um mich herum
wir würden vielleicht die
geräuschkulisse ist geprägt von kindern
wo kinder sind ist es nicht ganz traurig
ich sehe man sieht frauen und kinder man
sieht weinende frauen und lachende
kinder ging da ist es halt ist es halt
ein abenteuer und ich sitze hier
inmitten von
und spielsachen
wenn man wie man hier sieht so sieht die
so sieht er raum hier aus
über spielsachen
gruppen von menschen die sich die sich
die auf ihrem gepäck sitzen und man hört
geschnatter und
es ist hat
die menschen die hier ankommen
nicht wissen ob sie jemals in ihr
zuhause zurückkehren werden und sie
wissen auch nicht wo sie hingehen werden
die europäische union hat ja jetzt
bereitschaft erklärt menschen
aufzunehmen für jahre aber
was was tun wenn man ankommt und nicht
englisch und kein englisch und keine
sprache der europäischen union spricht
die familie unsere fotografin mit den
ich hier unterwegs spielen geht da
spricht
über 60 jährige mutter russische und
ukrainische tochter die im mittel 30
spricht englisch und stern idee ist nach
kanada weil sie in kanada eine große
ukrainische community gibt und so wird
jetzt hat in der frage in spanien das
als begingen wir jetzt erstmal für zwei
tage unter und dann wird sie
persönlichen freunden nach madegwa
zufrieden und dann sich die zeit nehmen
weil jetzt überlegen was aus ihrem leben
werden sei nicht weil diese menschen
haben gelegen aufs erste vielleicht
verloren man da ist ja nichts wie dieser
krieg weitergeht aber die ist
abschicken
möglicherweise auch immer auf ihn
[Musik]